Okay, I think it's time to get started.
Thank you very much everyone for coming.
And
this is a session about microenvironmental determinants of tumor
evolution and immune escape,
another component of tumor microenvironment.
And we will be your chairs for today,
and we will have seven exciting talks in the program.
And
we will get started right now. Remember that
please actively contribute to the discussions and questions, and
our only requirements for speakers, try to stay on time.
It's a 10-minute talk and five minutes questions.
You will see the timer on the screen.
When it's 10 minutes, it will be yellow color
and your talk is supposed to end. When you run out of 15
minutes, it will be a red color and no more time for questions,
unfortunately. And without further ado, I
think we will have our first speaker, Yi Zheng from
Columbia University, and he will talk about neuroinflammatory memory
in gastric tumorgenesis.
Thanks
for the introduction. Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm Yi from Columbia University. Today, I will talk
about vagal sensory neuron inflammatory memory.
We all know that H. pylori eradication reduces the risk of
gastric cancer. However, a large RCT with up to
26 years of follow-up revealed important
limitation. Even after a successful eradication,
gastric cancer still occurred in about 2.6%
of treated individual. A risk that
remains potentially higher than that of general population.
Interestingly,
patients with dyspeptic symptoms derive little to no
benefit
from eradication therapy. Together, these findings suggest that
eliminating the pathogen alone is not sufficient.
Instead, they raise the possibility that a form of persistent
inflammatory memory, potentially involving the gut-brain
axis, remain after bacterial clearance.
So before going further, let me briefly define what do we mean by
inflammatory memory.
Inflammatory memory can be defined as tissues or
cells retaining a memory of inflammatory injury that
acquisition to react more quickly and
broadly to subsequent diverse secondary stimuli.
In the pancreas and Crohn's, epithelial memory of
inflammation limits tissue damage in subsequent episodes of
acute inflammation while promoting tumorigenesis.
So this brings us back to a central question.
Can neuron themselves store inflammatory memory?
For example, in a DSS colitis model, reactivation
of insular cortex neural activity during primary inflammation
is sufficient to induce secondary Crohn's inflammation.
And these findings indicate that the nervous system can
encode and reactivate information about
prior inflammatory states.
However, while a similar neural memory
exists in the stomach and how it might influence
long-term disease outcomes remains unknown.
To study inflammatory memory in a physiologically
relevant manner, we employed a set of
complementary
gastric regeneration and tumor model.
For gastric regeneration, we primarily use a high-dose tamoxifen model,
which induces parietal cell loss and chief cell loss, and
triggers PEN, a kind of metaplastic response,
and normally resolve back to histological
baseline within three weeks.
Using the high-dose tamoxifen model,
we observed a striking memory phenotype in the stomach.
We use immunofluorescence for parietal cell, chief cell,
and spin cell, and proliferation.
Mice that had experienced a single prior
injury and fully returned to histological
baseline displayed a markedly accelerated
regenerative and metaplastic response upon a
second injury.
Importantly, the enhanced recall
response was not transient.
The memory effect persists for at least six months
after the initial injury. A similar phenotype
could be observed in a clinically relevant manner.
In mice previously infected with H.
pylori and subsequently eradicated, we
induced the HDD injury.
Although gastric histology appeared comparable to control
before injury, mice with an inflammatory history
showed significant accelerated regeneration and
metaplastic response during recall with increased
parietal cell and metaplastic cell.
However, this accelerated recall response comes
at a cost.While inflammatory
memory enhances regeneration, it has deleterious
consequences in the context of cancer.
The memory effect accelerated
orthotopic ACKP tumor progression,
and a similar phenotype can be observed in
multiple spontaneous cancer models, including
the intestinal type and diffuse type.
These findings indicate that the memory, although
beneficial for tissue repair, creates a permissive
microenvironment for tumor
progression. So next,
we sought to link the memory phenotype to the sensory
nerve system. Of course, both regeneration
and tumor model recall injury was consistently
associated with an increased CGRP
positive density
fibers at the lesion site. In parallel, we observed
a selective CGRP increase in the
Trpv1 positive sensory neuron within the nodose ganglion,
while
neurons of dorsal root ganglion origin were
not comparably engaged.
To directly test whether vagal sensory neurons
are required for the memory phenotype, we selectively transected
the anterior vagal trunk,
denervating the anterior gastric wall.
Compared to the
innervated posterior wall, the denervated region completely
lost the accelerated regeneration and tumor-promoting
memory effects. So whether
this memory could be traced at the level of
individual neurons using a
force-dependent head-off laboring strategy, we
permanently marked
the neurons activated during the first injury and
using tocilazole to stop laboring after the first
injury.
And then by using pERK
as a marker of neural activation during recall, we found
that reinjury activated a significantly larger number
of nodose ganglion neurons than the initial injury,
with a substantial overlapping with the neurons labeled
during the first injury. To
determine whether memory resides in a
specific subset of neurons, we
selectively ablated the neurons activated during the first
injury using a force-dependent head-off strategy.
In this setting, recall injury failed to
induce regeneration and tumor progression, demonstrating that the
memory-encoded nodose ganglion neurons are necessary for the
recall.
Finally, transportation of memory-encoded nodose
ganglion into Trpv1
positive neuron deficient recipients was sufficient to
restore the regenerative and tumor-promoting memory,
indicating that this neuron persists over time and
carry transferable inflammatory memory.
So next key question comes whether this
memory requires immune input, and if so,
which immune compartment is involved.
Using Rec1 deficient mice and Brg mice,
which means Rec deficient but also deficient in
IL-2 receptor gamma chain, we found that the memory phenotype
is independent of adaptive immunity, but strictly depends
on the innate immune system.
Through systemic profiling, we
identified gastric ILC2 as the only immune
population capable of supporting the memory phenotype.
During memory establishment, IL-25-positive
ILC2 remained persistently enriched
and was spatially positioned near the sensory
fiber endings within the grand
isthmus region and the tumor region.
To directly test whether ILC2 are required for
the memory formation, we selectively ablated ILC2
using the IL-5 Cre-IDT mice.
Loss of ILC2 completely abolished the
memory-associated phenotype.
Conversely, transplantation of HDT-activated
ILC2 into Brg mice
was sufficient to restore inflammatory memory.
Similarly, conditioned media from activated
ILC2 was able to prime
nodose ganglion in vitro and even with enhances the
capacity to promote epithelial organoid growth.
So this led us to ask a final mechanistic
question: How do ILC2 write memory into
sensory neurons?
Using CGRP ELISA and calcium
imaging of the nodose ganglion, we found that
ILC2-derived IL-5 stimulates
CGRP release from sensory neurons, and this
effect is markedly amplified in
memory-encoded neurons.
This heightened responsiveness reflects the fact that the
memory neurons express elevated
levels of type II cytokine receptors.
Interestingly, while a knockdown of IL-5
receptor only partially weakened the memory phenotype,
only disruption of IL-13 receptor
completely abolished the inflammatory memory.
This result revealed IL-13 is the dominant signal
that drives and stabilizes inflammatory
memory with the sensory neuron.So,
here are our memories for our research.
First, we found that the sensory neuron encoded a
long-term inflammatory memory in the stomach, and the neuronal
inflammatory memory drives metaplasia and
tumorigenesis upon a recurrent
injury. A memory recall enhances CGRP release
and gastric progenitor cell activation.
ILC2 signaling exacerbates immuno-neural epithelial memory
circuit. And finally, we found IL-13
epigenetically imprints and maintains
neuronal memory programs.
And thanks for listening.
Please feel free to raise any question, and I'm glad to
answer. Thanks.
Questions, please.
Maybe while we're waiting for more questions, I
can't get over the novelty of an
ILC2-dependent
memory of nerve injury and injury to epithelium.
What's
going on with ILC2s? Do you think it's just the
cytokine production that's somehow mediating this?
Thanks. That's a great question. Because of the
time limitation, we didn't show all the mechanism in our
slide here, but
I can provide the detail. After the ILC2
activation into the sensory neuron,
because ILC2 release some kind of cytokine
such as IL-5, IL-13, and
IL-5A.
And among them, IL-13 will cause some
epigenetic change in the sensory neuron.
We have confirmed that some obvious epigenetic
changes such as H3K4 trimethylation and
found some key regulators such as specific
methyltransferases that will induce
chromatin accessibility during the memory
period. That's the mechanism basis of the
memory-encoded neuron. Thanks.
And another question I have with regard to sensory
neurons, what are the
ramifications of eating a lot of
capsaicin in this model, and depleting
sensory neurons in humans or in mice?
There will be then less inflammation and no inflammatory
memory?
Thanks. That's a really interesting point.
And we define the
inflammation memory circuit as
needed of the
immune input. And so for the human, we didn't
examine the sample about the inflammation.
But we used a very similar clinical
relevant manner, that is H. pylori infection and
eradication. That's the same process as the human disease.
And this model also confirmed that the memory from the sensory
neuron
are so previously related with the epithelial
phenotype. Thanks.
Thank you.
Over there. Yeah.
I think there's a small literature on TRPV1 positive vagal
signaling in the inflammation that can contribute to pancreatic disease,
in particular, diabetes and other conditions in the
GI. Could this be a general inflammatory tract for GI
tumorigenesis in the interface with ILC2, which is,
as pointed out, very interesting?
Thanks
for your question. It's also an interesting point.
We didn't check PD1 and PD-L1
that associated with the
sensory neuron signaling. And for the immune
input, we have some systemic profiling to
identify the role of ILC2.
Only after ablation of ILC2 that can
induce the loss of the memory phenotype.
So,
for other kinds of immune cells,
we can make sure that there are loss of the memory. Thanks.
Okay. Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Our next presenter is Dr. Naoko Ohtani
from Osaka Metropolitan University,
and she's going to be talking about T cell
exhaustion after steatosis in the tumor
microenvironment. Thank you, Dr. Ohtani.
Thank you very much for the kind introduction. My name is Naoko Ohtani.
And first of all, I would like to thank organizers for giving me the opportunity
to talk about the work here. Today, I'm going to talk about the mechanism
of MASLD-associated hepatocellular
carcinogenesis,
particularly focusing on T cell exhaustion in steatotic
tumor microenvironment.
So I have no COI to disclose.
Okay. Thank you very much. Over the past several decades, obesity has
become more prevalent in most developed countries, including recognizing some
major risk factor of several type of cancers, including liver
cancer. However, the molecular mechanism of how obesity
promote cancer have not been fully illustrated yet.
So, we are particularly focusing on the
MASLD-associated HCC, a typical obesity-associated HCC.
MASLD is a metabolic dysfunction associated steatotic
liver disease, so-called fatty liver.Around 25% to
30% of the global adult population, approximately 1.5
billion people, are estimated to have MASLD.
And hepatocellular carcinoma arising from MASLD has been increasing
worldwide, particularly in East Asia, Oceania, and
Europe.
However, unfortunately, ICF therapy, both
monotherapy and combination therapy, are
not effective in MASLD-associated HCC.
And monotherapy
even worsens the patients' survivals.
So we questioned why MASLD-associated liver
cancer is resistant to ICF therapy.
So to this end, we first set up the system to investigate
MASLD-associated liver cancer. Neonatal mice are treated with
DMBA, a chemical carcinogen, which frequently initiates oncogenic
mutation in the Ras gene, followed by normal diet or high-fat diet
for 30 weeks. And very interestingly, almost all the high-fat diet
mice developed hepatocellular carcinoma like this.
And we are using this model as a MASLD-associated HCC
model.
Using this model, we previously found that the long-term high-fat
diet increased gram-positive bacteria in the intestine,
and deoxycholic acid produced by this gram-positive
bacteria, deoxycholic acid,
circulate through the intrahepatic circulation to
provoke the serosinesis of hepatic stellate cells,
fibroblast cells in the liver tissues.
And moreover, this gram-positive bacteria also
provided
lipoteichoic acid, which is a cell wall component of the gram-positive bacteria,
into the liver to stimulate the inflammatory signal through
the toll-like receptor 2 signal to up-regulate the
serum susp gene expression as well
as Cox 2 expression to overproduce prostaglandin
E2 to suppress antitumor immunity.
In addition, we found that the caspase-1 and
caspase-11 activity is high in the steatotic liver
tissue, and this caspase activity created a
gastamin D
cleavage to create the small pore in the
cell membrane to create the gastamin D internal
mediated pore. Through this pore,
several suspectors such as IL-beta and
IL-33 exported to suppress antitumor
immunity.
And next we
wanted to search for biomarkers for the MASLD-associated
HCC. To this end, we have done the multiplex assay
using the patient's plasma, high-fat diet fed mouse
serum, and liver tissues. And we found that the
CXCL9 chemokine was commonly high
in these samples.
And we found that CXCL9 is highly
expressed in the LSEC,
liver sinusoidal endothelial
cells. And as you know, LSECs are located in the sinusoidal
area, like this. And also we found that the
microbial components such as LPS
or LTa, as well as the bacteria membrane vesicles
isolated from the MASLD patient's feces, were able to
up-regulate the CXCL9
in the
cultured LSECs.
And so
CXCL9 is a chemokine that can recruit
the T cells from the lymph node into the liver
tissue and through the CXCR3
receptor. So to block this axis,
we treated mice with the neutralizing antibody
for the CXCR3, and we found that
this antibody treatment significantly
reduced that
liver cancer development, like this.
Moreover, we found that the CXCL9 knockout mice as well as
LSEC-specific conditional CXCL9 knockout mice, showed
a significant reduced liver cancer development, like this.
And when we investigate the immune status, we found that
the ratio of exhausted T cells decreased
and the activated CD8 T cells increased.
However, the Treg status is
unchanged in the condition of the
CXCR3 antibody-treated status. So
suggesting that the CXCL9 is important to develop the
liver cancer. Next, we wanted to search for
which cells are important for the liver cancer
development, and we have done the single-cell T cell receptor
analysis
using the CD8 T cells isolated from the lymph node as well
as the liver tissues. And we found that
in the lymph nodes, TPEX, the progenitor-exhausted T
cells existed in the lymph node,
and showing some characteristic of TPEX, showing the
exhausted markers as well as the memory markers.
However, the same clone became completely
exhausted when the cells
entered into liver tissue, like this.
And we have done the trajectory analysis, and this trajectory
analysis showed a similar result, that the same
clone from the lymph node,
starting from the central memory T cells, became
TPEX and losing the memory markers, and
entered into the completely exhausted TECs,
combining with increasing expression of
exhausted markers.And in this
analysis, we found that the TEpCs and as well as
TEcs T cells highly express the
granzyme K. So we are interested in the granzyme K,
and this is one of the granzyme family.
However, they are very different from the granzyme B, and this
granzyme K has a caspase-1-like activity to
mature the iron beta like this. And also we
confirmed that the granzyme K is really
correlated with the PD-1 expression.
And as you know,
caspase-1 is able to create the
gasdermin D to create the immature domain to create the
small pore in the cell membrane. And we previously found that
through this gasdermin D cell membrane
pore, that some suspect factors such as iron beta are exported from
the hepatic stellate cells. So we treated
the hepatic cells, isolated primary hepatic cells
with the recombinant granzyme K, and we found that
the iron beta expression is highly upregulated by the
treatment of recombinant granzyme K.
And also interestingly, we found that the iron beta is
exported into the culture supernatant in this condition,
suggesting that granzyme K facilitates iron beta upregulation as well
as its export. And next we have created a
granzyme K knock-out
mice, and we found that the granzyme K knock-out mice shows
the
significantly reduced number of its development.
However, the granzyme K overexpression increased the liver
cancer development, suggesting that the granzyme K is involved in the
mass 30 associated HCC progression.
And next we
used the human samples, and we isolated CD8 T
cells using the human mass 30 associated HCC patient tissue.
And we have done the single cell T cell sequencing analysis.
And in these human cells, we found a similar
trajectory pathway from the central memory T cells
defects into the exhausted T cells.
And
similar to mouse model, TEpCs, TEcs
exhibited the high expression granzyme K as well.
And,
finally, we
have done the metabolome analysis, particularly focusing
on the oxidized lipid oxylipin, and we found that a
series of oxylipins are high in the
high fat diet fed mouse liver. And a series of
oxylipins are able to
develop
from naive T cells into the TEpCs like this.
And also this oxylipin E, sorry, I'm not showing the
real name, but oxylipin E was able to develop
exhausted T cells from the TEpCs. So
we have done this experiment because the steatotic
liver is highly lipid rich, so we thought that the
oxylipins may be involved in.
So, this is a summary slide, and
CXCL3 positive CD8 T cells are recruited
from the lymph nodes by the
CXCL9 chemokine produced by the LFX.
And this TEpCs became exhausted in the
steatotic liver condition and expressed the granzyme K.
And the granzyme K facilitates the
iron beta export from the hepatic stellate cells to facilitate the liver
cancer development. And we first questioned why is the ICL
therapy is,
why mass 30 HCC is resistant to the ICL therapy.
So maybe one of the answers is maybe granzyme K
upregulation in TEpCs and TEcs in mass 30
HCC is involved in the
ineffectiveness of ICL therapy. So this is the end of
my talk, and thank you very much for your attention.
Great talk. I
have to ask whether you feel that this is a reversible
T cell exhaustion. Can this be reversed
in terms of dietary changes or
any drugs that might be available yet?
Yes.
We haven't checked that point yet, but a TEpCs is
thought to be reversible,
maybe
to some extent. So it is worth challenging,
focusing the TEpCs to reverse into the active T cells.
Yeah.
Granzyme K is highly expressed in NK cells.
Does any of your work address the potential role of NK here?
We haven't checked the NK cells, but thank you very much for
important information. We will check that. Thank you very much.
And I had another question. So there were earlier publications
that in NASH HCC, CD8
cells may be good or bad, and they may be bad by
killing lipid-loaded hepatocytes and inducing
compensatory proliferation. Is it possible that actually some of the
function of CD8 is
to kill hepatocytes and then to become exhausted-
Yeah.
-in the process?
Okay, thank you very much. Important question, and I think that's possible
because the chronic liver hepatitis background,
so there's some CD8, active CD8
is involved in the hepatitis itself.
So maybe it's possible, and we have to carefully investigate that.
Thank you very much.
I have one more question. Do you think that the
factors driving T cell exhaustion in this model
are systemic, or are they localized to the liver?
Yeah. Actually, we are thinking that that should be local, and so
we investigated
a little bit metabolome analysis and found out some slight
importance. But
basically, there's a obesity problem, probably
systemically. So maybe some other important factor
circulating in the body should exist.
And also in this model, can you estimate how much
IL1 beta actually comes from CD8 T cells
and the rest probably comes from myeloid cells, but maybe
context is important that CD8s are interacting
exactly with the cellular targets of IL1 beta, and that's why?
Right.
You are asking the IL1 beta origin
itself. Yeah, that's important. And actually,
at the same time, we were doing the spatial
transcriptomic analysis. So we would like to check carefully
the neighboring cells expressing IL1 beta.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
If
there are no more questions, thank you so much.
Thank you very much.
Our next speaker will be Shuyang He from
WashU, St. Louis, and she will talk about stress remodeling
of enteric neural system
in colitis to cancer transition.
All right. Thank you for the introduction. Is the sound okay?
All right.
So cancer patients are undergoing all different kind of stresses
from being diagnosed to all through all these treatments, and also
worry about the
collapse. So it is of note that one-third of the cancer
patients will develop a mental health problem, and half of
them will experience anxiety or depression.
From large scale of epidemiological studies, we know that
stress-related psychosocial factors associated with
higher incidence and poorer survival in cancer patients.
Social support, on the other hand, which can release the stress from the
cancer patients, has been proved with longer survival in these
patients. So as a systemic effect, it means
that stress can affect our whole body.
So my lab is of particularly interested in the gut system now.
So it is not only because the gut is closely related to our daily
life, but also because colorectal cancer is ranking number three in
the United States, meaning a lot of people are stressed out about this.
So although there are many evidence showing that genetic mutations like
KRAS or APC are driving the colorectal cancer onset,
there are more and more studies showing that these bad
lifestyle factors are also associated with the early
onset of colorectal cancer, including mental stress.
So to further understand the relationship between stress and the colorectal
cancer onset, we first looked into the published database
from the UK Biobank, which has a huge amount of population
data. For example, as shown here, when comparing
these patients with psychiatric disorders, the risk of them
getting colorectal cancer is much higher.
Moreover, when grouping these patients into different
disorders like depression or anxiety or psychological
stress, the risk factors for them for the CRC
incidence is also higher than the healthy controls.
So to further understand how stress promotes the colorectal cancer
onset, we went back to the mouse models in the lab.
From the past several years, we and others have used
different mouse models to study how stress promotes cancer
progression. And we have identified that stress by
activation of the HPA axis through the release of the stress
hormone like glucocorticoids, where stress can activate the sympathetic
nervous system in the mice.
So to really mimic the stress response in the mouse, we're now using
a physical restraint model to mimic stress.
So as shown here, the physical restraint model can lead to much higher
levels of corticosterone, which means that these mice are under
stress.
So with this model being established, we next combine it with the
colorectal cancer model. So we first started with the Apc min
mouse model, in which all the mice carry a loss-of-function
mutation of the Apc gene, and this is also the first step for
CRC onset in most of the cancer patients.
As you can see here within this model, delayed physical restraint
stress can significantly promote tumor genesis, and these
mice have developed more numbers of the tumors.
So this indicates that under the same genetic background, being
stressed can promote the tumor initiation.
So this phenomenon was not only limited in this Apc min mouse model,
but can also be found in multiple mouse models, including the
inducible CRC model and the spontaneous model.
So in both cases, we have shown that daily stress can promote
more numbers
of the tumor happening throughout the gut, meaning that the stress can
really promote the cancer onset.
So before getting into any mechanistic studies, I
would like to highlight here that gut is a highly
innervated organ. So here I'm showing you a 3D whole mount
imaging from this cleared tissue.
You can see here the gut has extensive blood vessels, which are
mediating the nutrient absorption.
But around these blood vessels here is enteric nervous
system. It includes the enteric glia cells labeled in
red and the nerves stained in white.So these two
types of the cells, the nerves plus the glia cells, has made
this neuronal network within the gut, and they are
playing critical roles in maintaining the gut homeostasis.
So within this nervous system, we are focusing now on
the role of glia cells, given its known role during the
CRC development. So we first generated a gene
signature expressed exclusively by the enteric glia cells,
or the EGCs. When we applied this gene signature into the
TCGA database for CRC patients, I hope you can
appreciate that the patients who had the higher
expression of this gene signature, meaning that their tumors
probably are more infiltrated by glia cells, they actually had much
shorter survival time.
So to further understand or characterize the roles of
EGCs during the CRC development, we next compared
the EGC infiltration across different stages
during the CRC development. However, to our surprise,
we found that there are a lot of glia cells infiltrated into
the polyps or the benign tumors at the initial stage.
As you can see here, the glia cells are labeled in green with
as 100 beta staining, and they're hanging around the cancer cells in
red.
However, when the tumors grow larger or become more advanced, we could
barely find any glia cells inside.
So this data has prompted us to think about the role of EGC in the
initial stage. So we next decided to deplete them.
We took advantage of a mouse strain called
Plp1creERT RosatTTR mice, in which we could
specifically deplete the glia cells in the gut following
the injection of tamoxifen and diphtheria toxin.
So, as confirmed here, we show that the glia cells can be
largely depleted in the gut. So we then
back cross this mouse strain within the ApcMin background
and subjected all these mice into this stress-induced CRC model.
So I think the data is pretty striking by just looking at this picture.
So simply by depleting the
glia cells at the very early stage could significantly
reduce stress-induced tumorigenesis.
So after identifying that the glia cells are in the tumor
microenvironment to promote tumor initiation, we were
then wondering, how do these glia cells promote
tumorigenesis? So we then turn
back to our in vitro culturing system.
So we generated the organoid line from this ApcMin mice.
We call it as a pre-tumor organoid lines.
And at the same time, we also collected the conditioned medium from the
stressed glia cells, meaning that we pre-treated the cells with the
glucocorticoid or the GR receptor
agonist.
So what we found is that when treating this pre-cancer organoid with the
conditioned medium from stressed glia cells, can significantly
promote the outgrowth of these organoids.
So to better understand at the molecular level, how do these glia
cells promote tumorigenesis, we next perform the qPCR on
this pre-cancer organoid. As you can appreciate here, all these
tumorigenesis-related genes have been all
upregulated when treating these organoids with the conditioned
medium from stressed EGCs.
So to further understand any clinical relevance of our study,
we next compared the cross-species of our data.
As you can see here, what we have found for these transcriptional changes
in the mouse organoid can be very well recapitulated with a
human database.
So after knowing that the EGCs are in the microenvironment
playing some role in promoting tumorigenesis, we next are wondering,
is there any cell intrinsic response to stress?
So to study this, we look at the early time point in our model.
So getting inspired by previous studies showing that stress can
induce reactive oxygen species, or ROS, in the gut, we
next examined this oxidative damage within our
system. As you can see here, with
two different marker staining, we show that the gut tissue from the
stressed mice do have elevated ROS, indicating that they
are undergoing oxidative damage.
So consequently of this oxidative damage, we
also found that the gut cells from the stressed mice do show more
DNA double-strand damage, as indicated by
gamma-H2AX staining.
But it's very interestingly that, although under all different kinds
of damage, these gut cells from the stressed
mice are also hyperproliferating.
So here, as indicated by the Ki-67 staining, these
abnormal damaged cells are hyperproliferating, and maybe
this is the reason that they will undergo tumorigenesis.
So in summary, our data has generated
a stressed EGC-stem cell axis, and by activating
this axis can trigger the tumor
initiation in the mice. Magnetically, we found that
the stressed glia cells, meaning that the activation of the GR
pathways in these glia cells, are the driver in the gut
microenvironment to trigger all these transcriptional changes in the
stem cells, and finally becoming a tumor cell.
So within this project, we also have some open questions
for the future direction. First, the glia cells are really
heterogeneous. So from recently published single-cell
data, we know that there are at least four types of glia cells
throughout the gut. So what we don't know is that if there is any
location-specific or subtype-specific response
to stress of these glia cells, and how this can be involved in
cancer.So second, so for this project, we
are working on understanding the glia's crosstalk with the stem
cells, but they're also surrounded with other cell types.
For example, whenever we did the staining for the glia cells, they always
come along with the nerve cells. So what we don't know is that under stress
condition, if there's any change of the nerves and whether and how this can
be involved during the stress-induced tumor genesis.
So with that, I would like to thank my lab members, especially
Xiaoxiao, she's here, she's a mom now, and Chenchen.
They are contributing significantly to this project, and happy to take
any questions.
Questions, please.
Quick question about can you simplify your model,
stress or no stress, if you just inject cortisol?
Will it produce all the effects on glia and
then on colitis or spontaneous tumor genesis?
This is a very good question. I think my trainees will be very happy to know
because they have to come to
lab every day to stress the mice. And I think the simple answer
is yes, because we tried in a different model with breast
cancer, in which we injected dexamethasone to mimic
stress response, and we saw the same
results for breast cancer liver metastasis, but we haven't tested in the
gut.
Okay.
Yeah. Tim Wong from Columbia. Really nice talk.
Thank you.
I like that you used the restraint stress model, which is very reproducible.
So you focus a lot on the HPA axis, and you focus more on the
glucocorticoid response, but you really didn't mention the
adrenergic response and the effects of epinephrine and norepinephrine,
which go up under stress and maybe under cold conditions.
So did you look at whether or not adrenergic
signaling played a role? Did you look at ADRP2 signaling, for
example?
Yes, very good question. So in another independent
project with breast cancer, we actually look at the sympathetic
nerves. We found that activation of the nerves specifically
locally in the breast can also promote tumor growth in the
primary site. But in the gut, it's a little bit different.
So we try to identify the nerve types within the gut,
and we found in the colon, these sympathetic nerves are really
located in the smooth muscle layer.
So when we dissected other neuron types, we found it's mostly like
VIP or vasoactive intestinal peptide, VIP
positive nerves, and endos positive nerves in the gut and also in the
tumor. So we guess probably it's not the
sympathetic nerves directly
working on, but it is also possible because
it's innervated into the smooth muscle layer,
which has a lot of ganglia. So there's a possibility that it
talks to the ganglia of the nerves in the gut and then
transmit the signal into the tumor, but we haven't looked at it.
Great question. Thank you.
Please.
Thanks for your fascinating presentation.
I just have a question about the gut microbiome.
A lot of the bacteria that are associated with psychiatric disorders
are also associated with
colonic tumorigenesis.
And I was wondering if you can close the loop,
whether the glial cells impact the bacterial populations that are in
the gut,
or how do you think about the microbiome in light of your
work from a sort of systems point of view?
Great. I think this is a very good question.
So we actually have a project ongoing in my lab in which we are looking at
how stress affects the colitis. And we have some preliminary data of
this microbiome composition in the stressed mice, and we do
see a lot of changes in terms of the species of microbiome.
And we found some of them are closely related to ulcerative colitis in
human. But what we don't know is that whether it's related to the
glia cells or the stress itself, or it is because stress can induce
a leaky gut, and then this leaky gut can promote
local inflammation, which will change the microbiome.
So we don't know yet, but this is very good.
Okay, thanks.
Okay, thank you so much.
Next, we're going to move into the setting of head and neck cancer,
squamous cell carcinoma progression, and hear about the
epithelial myeloid circuit
from Dichen Lin. Dr. Lin is from the University of Southern
California.
Thank you. Thanks so much for the introduction and invitation.
I'm very excited to share some of the works from the lab that we are
looking into the cancer development via the
single-cell plus spatial characterization to understand,
in this case, tumor monocytes crosstalk.
Nothing to disclose. So
switching gear a little bit,
head and neck squamous cancer. So this is a pretty common cancer around
the world. Not too much in
United States, but
every year there are 600,000 cases around the world.
And then squamous cell is the most dominant cancer
type, and then it's a very aggressive cancer, especially for the HPV
negative subtype.
The five-year survival, it's been stagnant for the far past, maybe two decades.
It's been
lower than 50%.
So it's this pressing need for innovative
research and drug development for this
disease.So in terms of microenvironment,
we wrote a little comment last year to highlight, just like
many other cancer types, the
diversity in terms of the microenvironment is pretty profound, and
there are patient-specific tumor microenvironment, which explains the
failure rate about 80% if you look at the ICB treatment in the clinic.
And so in this case, we're thinking about the heterogeneous
cell-cell crosstalk between different subtypes of cancer cells and the different
subtypes of myeloid cells. And so specifically, we collected
and we also sequenced our own patients.
So you're looking at about 167 samples from
114 patients. This is led by
Dr. Park, which sits there. So we have samples
across the disease
settings from normal premalignant tumor,
metastatic tumors, and recurrent tumors.
And
so with that data set, we look
into different
cell clusters. And so paying more attention to myeloid
cells, which you're looking at about 14 subsets here, standard
UMAP annotation. So if you look at this,
number 7, we call that tumor-enriched monocyte,
because if you look at the x-axis from distal normal to
precursor tumor,
you see a jump in terms of the
ratio,
sort of normalized the ratio. And then we are very interested in this
because across different cohorts, you see
very consistent association between the high amount
of this monocytic fraction
and the poor survival
in different patient cohorts, including
ICB-treated cohorts.
And then this subset also is very
featuring the high expression of immunosuppressive genes,
and then angiogenesis genes, so even higher than a
commonly used positive control SPP1 positive macrophages.
So this is even higher than that one.
And then we looked through different cancer types, and you can see that across
different cancer types that you see consistent enrichment of this cell
type in the tumor
specimens, especially also with the
pre-inflamed or pre-cancer
lesions. But you see that the increase is very tumor
specific. And then if you look at the pseudo time and trajectory
analysis,
this is a public data set.
So there are blood samples and the tissue samples, and
this subset of monocyte, you can see that the
slingshot shows that the trajectory is kind of deviated from the
development from the CD14 classical monocyte to
the macrophage to
CD16 positive monocyte. So this is pretty distinct.
So we believe that this is still a intratumor monocytic
population rather than a fully differentiated macrophage.
So, to understand the cell interaction, we took a published
method to use the UMF to sort of distill the
cell interaction. So basically, we nominate the nodes
and the edges based on the
weight of the UMF and then also pairwise correlation between the cell fraction.
And then with that, we can basically
identify modules. Here you can see these modules show
very high correlation among themselves, and very
interesting module six, it's very high in almost
absent in any precursor lesions, but very high in the
tumor. And why we're interested, because this is very high in
terms of this monocytic population, and it's also
enriched with
this so-called hybrid EMT or partial EMT, which
is recurrently now mentioned in the head and neck and other squamous tumors.
And then the correlation is also very, very specific for tumor.
You can see that the correlation is rather
very random in the precursor or distal regions, but
very
enriched in the primary tumor and the metastatic tumor.
And from here, the hybrid EMT or partial
EMT tumors, also just like the monocytic
subset, they're always associated with worse survival
across different patient cohorts in head and neck cancer.
And to further understand their interaction, we did
VZMHD,
the spatial sequencing to look at
their locations. And here you can see the co-occurrence score
based on
anchoring the tumor at the center.
And then you can see that
the modeled
score shows that the tumor-enriched monocyte is
really the
highest among all the module six subtypes.
So it suggests the direct proximity
between this monocytic cells and the hybrid
EMT tumors, and you can visually see them
across many regions in the tumor. They basically touch each other very often.
And then this is the other way to look at it.
So if you look at
50 micrometer, which is a reasonable
distance, you see that across different-- So
we also basically analyzed the subtypes
of the tumor. So highly differentiated, cell cycling
tumors and hypoxic tumors or oxidative tumors.
So all different cell subtypes of tumors, the hybrid
EMT or partial EMT always shows the highest correlation,
the
spatial closeness to this subtype of
monocytic cells, and this is another way to look at the distance.
If you rank them, the closest, the shortest distance...
occurring the partial EMT cells. And we can also
quantify the scores based on their distance.
So we ask, for example,
the tumor cells that are close to these monocytes versus tumor cells that are far
away from the monocyte, which tumor cells have the higher, let's say, EMT score.
And you can see that the more
close they are, the higher score you can see from
tumor cells. And
then the same is true for these monocytic cells.
I showed you the immunogenetic scores that is very high in these monocytic cells.
And then when they're closer to the partial
EMT tumors, they're also higher. So
it shows that from this correlation analysis, you
can see the spatial distance really dictates their
functional
status, at least from the gene expression level.
And you can
see that in the TCGA based on bulk data, the
hybrid EMT score and the monocytic
score is highly, highly correlated.
So that suggests sort of a functional crosstalk between these two
cell types. And then to understand that, we started
the patient using organoid modeling.
So basically, we took
PBMC-derived monocytes, and we co-cultured them
in patient-derived organoids.
And then we created a matrix liquid interface so
that these monocytic cells can really move around and
interact with the tumors because the matrix is
pretty dense, and monocytes, immune cells don't
move very well, but in this case, they can actually move and
infiltrate. So then after five days, you take these cells out,
and you look at the molecular changes.
So the first thing you see is that the signature scores
of the monocyte
compared to the
culture alone, the monocytic cell alone, and the different patient
organoids really enhance the expression of
these monocytic genes up to
150-fold. So it's pretty huge. And
then in the standing, you can also see that
CD14+ monocyte, you co-culture with the...
So we use ITGB4 as one of the marker genes for the
HME, hybrid EMT cancer cells. So you see that
life imaging shows that some of the... So this is a confocal.
You see that some of the monocytes actually can infiltrate into the
organoids, and you quantify that.
And then we did one, two, three, four, five, six
patients so far. So
we stratified them by EMT high, EMT low
patients.
So you see that EMT low versus EMT high, you see that the hybrid,
this is EMT high organoids,
tumors infiltrate, recruit more monocytes
into this tumor mass versus the low
counterparts. And
when you look at the organoid themselves, also you see that
before and after the co-culture, you see the ITGB4, this one of
the markers. So we see that
increased also pretty significantly after they
see the monocytes.
So suggesting that
they have functional crosstalk.
So to further prove that whether
hybrid EMT does impact the recruitment and
the reprogramming of these monocytes, we
use flow to sort cancer cells into
EMT high, EMT low based on PDP and ITGB4.
This is single-cell derived markers.
And then
after sorting them out, we incubate them with the monocyte, just like before I
showed you. And then you see that
compared to double, sorry about the resolution, it's kind of low.
Double negative
cells, which is hybrid EMT low, versus
the double positive, which is hybrid EMT high.
You see this very
distinguishing difference. So the cancer cell, if it's double
negative, it does go up, but very minimally, but with the double
positive, it goes up to sixfold,
suggesting that the cancer intrinsic hEMT
status really can dictate their
impact on the monocytic
cell state.
And then after the co-culture, we also took out these cancer
cells, and we look at their hybrid EMT gene expression.
And you can see the panel of genes here, some of the classical EMT genes,
some of them are the squamous sort of identity genes here.
And after co-culture with the monocyte, these cancer cells also
express much, much higher hybrid EMT markers.
And then you can also look at the math flow.
So
the hybrid EMT low organoids, they
do go up, but very minimally, but after co-culture with the
monocyte, the hybrid EMT high organoid, these patients,
their EMT signature goes even higher from 10% to
20% to 30%. So that's
basically showing that vice. So this is a bidirectional
crosstalk between hybrid EMT
tumor cells and this subset of
monocytic cells. Basically, they impact each other to increase the,
at least in the gene expression and protein standing level, the EMT
markers and then the monocytic androgenetic genes.
So to put that into more in the cancer context, we
and others, we've shown extensively
theThe function of hyper EMT in squamous biology, basically,
it promotes not only the invasion metastasis but also
drug resistance, radiation plus cisplat in this case, which is
commonly used in treating head and neck cancer patients in the clinic.
So you see that with cisplatting alone,
the killing is about 50% ish, but in this case, we're using
THP1 as a model system
to show that. Okay, I'm done. I thought that's the time.
That's it.
Oh, I'm confused.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm done. This is the last one.
So with the
monocyte being there, you see the cancers don't really
die much. And then last one, this last piece.
So basically in vivo you can see the tumor cell along, this is
survival. And then if you co-implant them with the monocyte,
they die much faster. But then the last piece is if you
inject the
monocyte into the circulation, after 20 days you actually
see them being actively recruit to the tumor microenvironment through the
bloodstream, so showing that there is active
recruitment into the microenvironment.
And that also reduced survival. So that's it. That's the little summary here.
I'm going to skip that. And then lastly, I want to thank the lab
members who are very dedicated and talented postdocs
I'm blessed to work with. Thanks so much. I'll take any questions.
Thank you. We have
time for two quick questions.
Go.
One question I have, so EMT high cancer cells are more
fibroblast-like, right? There is a concept that there is a
tissue
unit of fibroblast,
macrophage or monocyte, and epithelial cell.
Do you think if you incorporate into your cultures cancer-associated
fibroblasts-
Mm-hmm
... then monocytes will be uniquely
skewed towards what you see regardless of the
epithelial characteristics, and everything will be dictated by fibroblasts?
That's a very nice question. I don't think so.
I think there has to be cancer present, but in the computational
analysis we do see there's myofibroblasts also in that community.
So,
hey, Dr. Wang.
Yeah. Nice talk. So in terms of your TIMO monocytes,
do you think they play any role in immune suppression?
That's the biggest focus for the monocyte field these days.
And for your TIMO monocytes, there've been a lot of failures in trying to deplete
monocytes and treat cancer. Do you have any specific targets for TIMO?
Yeah. Thanks so much. That's a very insightful question.
Absolutely. So as I mentioned,
we found the TIMO enrichment also is very
strongly associated with ICB treated failure.
And then we actually were starting to look at this, so
when we do a
trio culture, you put T cells in, put monocyte, we put the patient-derived
tumor organoids, there is a dampening in terms of at least the
activation markers of these T cells.
We don't know the killing effect yet, but at least the flow level
shows that there's decreased CD69, decreased granzyme B levels.
So we believe there will be
a somewhat impact on T cell activation.
In terms of the dependency, yes, I think
it's not been very fruitful in terms of targeting them, but we do think there's a
metabolic
vulnerability in terms of in this specific subset.
I'm not ready to show any of the data here, but we do think
that's a promising future lead to follow up. Thank you.
Okay, I think we are
out of time.
Thanks so much.
Okay.
So
our next speaker is Maria Hernandez from University
of Florida, and
chronic sleep deprivation promotes colon cancer, and
she will tell us how microbiota
factors in to this process.
Good afternoon, everyone. Thank you for the kind introduction.
I'm excited to share my
graduate work at the University of Florida, and I have
nothing to disclose.
There's a common factor among many cancer patients, is that sleep
deprivation. In fact, over 60% of patients have reported
sleep disturbances prior to cancer diagnosis, and in fact,
over 60% of them experience these disturbances after
diagnosis and even into treatment.
However, we don't know the biological mechanisms by which sleep
deprivation affect cancer progression.
However, we do know in the literature that sleep deprivation
significantly increases the abundance of pro-inflammatory cytokines in
the host that can act through the systemic circulation and
nearby lymphoid tissues. These changes have been
associated with immunosuppression within the immune landscape of the host.
For example, through decreased cytotoxic T cell frequency, as
well as decreased antigen presentation, which are both key for
antitumor immunity.
And these changes have overall been associated with increased risk in
colorectal cancer development, as well as cancer risk.
Similarly, the field has established that sleep deprivation can negatively
modulate the microbiome by altering its structure, for
example, through elevating the ratio of Firmicutes to
Bacteroides. Now, the novelty of our work is aiming to
understand how sleep deprivation induced dysbiosis
drives colorectal cancer development and further can
decrease treatment response.
To study our central hypothesis, we employed a model of chronic sleep
deprivation. Using these commercially available cages,
we housed mice,
where a bar sweeps across the floor of the bar every two minutes
for 12 hours a day from 7:00 a.m. to 7:00
p.mThis works because mice are nocturnal, but it's
meant to mimic a human being awake in the evening.
The mouse models we used were Black 6 male mice, ages eight to
12 weeks old. And we employed a murine
adenocarcinoma model
of MC38. The majority of the samples in the readouts
were stools for 16S rRNA gene sequencing, as
well as tumor for qPCR analysis of mRNA gene expression,
as well as using flow cytometry to analyze tumor-infiltrating lymphocytes.
The first fundamental question we wanted to address was how sleep
deprivation, now I will label it as SD, can promote colorectal
cancer development. We pre-exposed the mice to seven
days of SD, and the control mice were housed in
the same room with the same light exposure and the same
temperatures. After a seven-day exposure to the SD mice, we
implanted both the SD as well as the control with half a million
MC38 cancer cells, and we followed through with tumor growth
until a significant endpoint.
To assess how this
regimen of SD was affecting circadian rhythm expression,
we took endpoint tumor tissue and explored
circadian rhythm gene expression.
For example, as you can appreciate,
one of the positive regulators, BMAL1, was significantly
decreased in the SD mice compared to the non-SD counterparts.
Similarly, the protein family Cry, both Cry 1 and Cry
2, were significantly elevated in tumor RNA compared to the
non-SD counterparts. This was also observed in the other core
protein, Per2.
In the context of tumor growth, we see that SD mice were
significantly more susceptible to tumor volume compared to the non-SD
counterparts. This was also associated with a significant
increase in tumor weight.
And in the context of tumor immunity, we observed that the SD
mice had a lower expression of
IL17A, IL1B, and TNF alpha,
likely alluding to an immunosuppressive tumor microenvironment.
But more importantly than tumor progression, we wanted to focus on
answering this fundamental question in another aspect of cancer care
that's important, like chemotherapeutic response.
5-FU has long been standing as a key drug for human colorectal
cancer. And so to assess this, we asked ourselves two fundamental
questions. How is our chronic SD regimen affecting 5-FU
efficacy? And how is a sleep-deprived
microbiota affecting 5-FU efficacy?
Similarly, as before, we employed the same model where SD mice
were housed in their cages and pre-exposed to seven days of chronic
SD.
After the seven-day exposure, we implanted them with the same concentration of
cancer cells. And when the tumors were palpable at day 10, we
began treating them with 5-FU at a concentration of
25 milligrams per kg via IP route.
The control mice were housed again in the same room and received the same tumor
implantation and the same treatments starting at day 10 and until
day 22. Endpoint was reached when the mice were at tumor endpoint.
You can appreciate that the SD mice receiving 5-FU were
significantly more susceptible to tumor growth compared to the
non-SD controls also receiving 5-FU.
This was also coupled with a significant increase in tumor weight.
In the context of tumor immunity, we observed that the SD mice
had a significant decrease in CD27 and
interferon gamma in tumor mRNA levels,
likely alluding to a decrease in T cell infiltration and cytotoxicity.
You can also appreciate a significant increase in IL6,
a pro-inflammatory cytokine associated with sleep deprivation.
More exciting for us, we were able to observe using flow cytometry
that the tumors of SD mice were significantly lower in
frequency of CD4 positive T cells, which are effector cells key
for anti-tumor immunity,
as well as they had a lower frequency of CD8 T
cells and interferon gamma CD8 T cells.
Sleep deprivation also affected the infiltration efficacy of
natural killer cells as well as granzyme A positive natural
killer cells. And you can appreciate that the overarching theme is that this
regimen significantly pushed the mice to a lower immune
activation. It made it more susceptible to a decrease in
5-FU efficacy.
Now, to understand how this regimen could be negatively affecting the
microbiota, we employed a validated model of
fecal microbiota transplantation that I will explain shortly.
Using the endpoint stool of the SD versus the
non-SD mice from the previous study I just showed you,
we took those stools and we prepared a pooled slurry of them.
Now, we took healthy Black 6 mice, all male,
and they were housed in the same facility near each other, received seven
days of antibiotic water cocktail, and after a 24-hour
washout period, we orally gavaged them with either a pool of the
SD stool slurry or the non-SD stool slurry.
We allowed for the microbiota in the
slurry to implant in the gut of the mice, and then we
implanted them with the same concentration of half a million MC38 cancer
cells on the right flank.
Same as before, on day 10, we began treatment with 5-FU via
IP and followed through for four more rounds and then measured the
mice until endpoint.
We collected stool at zero and at endpoint to assess
changes in the microbiota diversity using 16S
rRNA gene sequencing. You can appreciate that
at time point zero, the microbiota of the non-SD mice
compared to the SD mice clusters significantly different at the beta
diversity level.These changes
had also gone through until the
endpoint. As you can appreciate, the non-SD cluster tightly,
whereas the SD cluster separately at endpoint.
So not only do we see significant changes in the microbiota
sustained over a period of about 26 days, these
changes were also accompanied by functional changes in the mice.
You can appreciate that the recipient SD mice
receiving 5-FU had significant tumor growth
compared to the non-SD recipient mice treated with 5-FU.
The SD recipient mice were also more susceptible to a decrease in
TNF-alpha, a key pro-inflammatory cytokine important for anti-tumor
immunity. In the context of tumor-infiltrating lymphocytes, we
also saw a significant decrease in frequency of effector CD4
positive T cells, as well as cytotoxic CD8 positive T
cells.
So overall, our preliminary findings have demonstrated
that our chronic SD model can significantly modulate the
microbiota and create a dysbiosis or a lack of
homeostasis that can potentiate the growth of cancer cells
using an MC38 cancer model and a decrease in cornerstone
chemotherapy 5-fluorouracil.
I would like to thank my lab, the University of Florida, and our funding sources,
as well as AACR for this wonderful opportunity. Thank you.
That's very intriguing data. I have to ask,
and I'm sure you've been asked this many times and have thought about it, but we
all do our experiments during the day-
Mm-hmm.
When mice are supposed to be sleeping.
So we've kind of reversed their night and day to begin with.
So the animals you're using in this study presumably would've
been conditioned under those circumstances
before this experiment began.
Yeah.
How do you think that that may affect all of our
data, let alone,
then doing sleep deprivation studies?
Well, it's incredible because before I started working on this, I
didn't really understand how impactful circadian rhythm is.
Every cell of our body has a circadian rhythm.
Right.
And some of the things like our gut microbiomes respond to
that. So I think it's very important in all aspects of
cancer research to incorporate these very large
physiological systems that are taking place, like circadian rhythm,
because prior to studies, in circadian biology, yeah, it's not
really known, but-
Yeah.
Yeah. Thank you for bringing that out.
Yeah. Very important work.
Thank you.
Yes.
So,
first of all, thanks, Betsy, you asked my question.
Second question, but I have another suggestion.
It's about the experiment that you show at the end where you do the FMT
transfer.
Mm-hmm.
You took the mice at the end of the tumor growth.
You took the FMT from mice with tumor.
Yes.
Have you done that with just simple stool of mice
from
sleep deprivation and then performed the experiment?
We have not. But knowing that we have a preliminary phenotype, we're
working into expanding and increasing the rigor of our experiments.
So I appreciate you bringing that up. Thank you.
Sure.
Yes.
Good work, Maria.
Thank you.
I was wondering
if you have a confounding factor here that is stress.
Mm-hmm.
How can you differentiate between sleep deprivation or
the machine is actually-
Mm-hmm.
Alarming the animals constantly?
So I thank you for bringing that up.
Preliminarily, that's why I checked for circadian rhythmicity to assess that it was
affecting that axis of the host. But for our future studies, I will
definitely incorporate checking plasma levels of certain stress hormones
like glucocorticoid, or even other aspects of the
parasympathetic or sympathetic nervous system. So I think that's very important.
But something else about the mice and that I have read in the literature, they
tend to acclimate to certain stressors.
And because this is not an acute model and rather a stressful long-term chronic
model,
I anticipate that they're probably adapting to it.
But I definitely agree that molecularly, I need to determine that whether this is a
stress versus a sleep deprivation. So thank you for that.
Or both together.
Or both together. Absolutely. Thank you.
It's a good talk, actually. I just want to comment on your
experiment, where you used only the male mice.
Yes.
And circadian rhythm and bone colorectal cancer-
They're affected by estrogen.
Right.
So,
did you look into that also? Did you use female mice also?
We have not used female mice simply because we know that females have the
estrous cycle, and that does have fluctuation.
So we wanted to minimize that confounding variable.
As you can appreciate, the project is
taking a very wide leap, so I think we're just trying to
mostly concentrate on the microbiome as the highlight.
But I definitely agree that there's to be consideration of the female
sex and all of those factors, yeah.
Thank you.
I have a question about the applicability of your model-
Yeah.
To
the sleep problems we see in the clinic.
Mm-hmm.
Which are generally
sleep apnea-
Mm-hmm.
Or
mild to moderate, which is-
Mm-hmm.
Affects a surprising number of people.
Yeah.
Like 40%.
Yeah, definitely.
Like most-
And the sleep apnea tends to track with visceral adiposity also-
Mm-hmm.
Which creates another thing to try and dissect out of what we're
really measuring.
Mm-hmm.
How are you thinking about
extrapolating from what you've done in the lab?
So like most things, no model is perfect.
Whenever I try to implement... There are lots of different sleep deprivation models
in the literature. There's the jet lag model.
There is a model that specifically affects REM
sleep. And so we were trying to
model something that a human or a cancer patient would be
experiencing. So I think that's something that we should consider or
maybedo our chronic SD and maybe incorporate other models that will
likely... But yeah, it's not perfect.
It was meant to be more of an umbrella term, but not a specific sleep
condition because, as you know more, there are many, like insomnia,
sleep apnea, et cetera. So yeah, not a perfect model, but-
Thank you.
So sleep deprivation affects microbiota.
When you do FMT,
do clock genes change in immune cells or in the
tumor?
So I didn't show it here, but we have preliminary findings just from the tumor
RNA that BMAL1 was significantly altered in the
SD recipient mice. But we want to do further studies and
evaluate more of those changes in specifically other tissues other than just the
tumor.
Okay. Thank you so much.
Thank you very much.
Next, we're going to hear about obesity-induced
changes in adipose tissue in ovarian cancer by
Dr. Sophia Hou from San Diego
State University. You didn't have to come very far.
Yeah.
Yeah, thank you for the introduction and the invitation.
I am a PhD student, to clarify for the
audience. But yeah, I'm very excited to present my work to you, "The
Impact of Obesity-Induced Changes in Adipose Tissue on Ovarian
Cancer Progression."
So ovarian cancer is the most lethal gynecologic malignancy and can be
categorized into four different stages, where stages one and two is
where the cancer is confined within the pelvic region.
And then in stages three and four, the cancer has now spread to
the omentum, and the omentum is an abdominal fatty tissue sheet that
covers the peritoneal cavity.
And unfortunately, at stages three and four, this is where ovarian
cancer is most frequently caught due to its
nonspecific symptoms and lack of accurate predictive screening
tests. So, this makes understanding the
biology of metastatic colonization to the omentum
increasingly important.
When ovarian cancer metastasizes to the omentum, the
ovarian cancer cells establish a complex tumor microenvironment
enriched of the cancer cells, pre-adipocytes, adipocytes,
immune cells, fibroblasts that are secreting its own extracellular matrix
composed of collagen or fibronectin.
And there is cell-to-cell communication in the forms of IGF-1,
IL-6, or TNF alpha as examples. And
pre-adipocytes are precursors to fat cells, and they make up
15% to 50% of the stromal cell compartment and are
an important component of visceral fat.
And unlike lipid-rich adipocytes, their morphology is
fibroblast-like, and their secretome is enriched in proinflammatory and
tumor-supporting factors.
So a previous graduate student wanted to understand the role of these
pre-adipocytes in ovarian cancer tumor formation.
And so she did a limiting dilution injection model
where she injected 40 cancer cells to one pre-adipocyte, an equal
ratio of one to one, and then a one to 40 ratio.
And the
injections of cancer cells alone were not able to form tumors,
but with the presence of pre-adipocytes, this significantly enhanced
tumor growth. And
this one to 40 ratio is mimicking isolation stress, which
is a condition characteristic of metastasizing cells
that are colonizing the omentum where there is an abundance of pre-adipocytes.
And we further validated with injections of mature adipocytes
that both pre-adipocytes and mature adipocytes are generating
tumors similarly, as well as tumor growth.
And the cells were then subjected to
co-cultures between pre-adipocytes and adipocytes,
and there were significant
hits for cellular response to stress and extracellular matrix
organization, as well as regulation of IGF
transport. And I want to emphasize that this RNA
was taken from the cancer cells in co-culture.
And specifically here, these pre-adipocytes enrich
this
phenotype implicating insulin-like growth factor signaling
important for these cancer cells.
And IGF has vital effects on proliferation and survival,
and it was indeed increased in co-culture
with pre-adipocytes. And
IGF stimulation on cancer cells increased ECM
remodeling genes like collagen and fibronectin.
And in my preliminary experiments, I'm finding that
IGF is working in both nutrient-full and nutrient-depleted
conditions, activating phosphorylated AKT as well
as phosphorylated p65, which is associated with the
classical NF Kappa B pathway.
And obesity
increases the risk for several cancers, including ovarian, and its
dysfunctional adipose tissue creates a special and
permissive niche for ovarian cancer to spread and thrive.
And in an obesity mouse model, these researchers found that
there was increased metastasis to the omentum as well as to the
mesentery, and these are adipose-rich sites.
And in a different study, these
omental adipose tissue were taken from obese and
morbidly obese patients, and there was increased IGF expression as
well as activation of the IGF receptor.
So all of these potential links led us to want to understand this
obesity-mediated IGF
signaling in ovarian cancer metastasis.
So I have hypothesized that obesity increases
pre-adipocyte-mediated activation of IGF-1 signaling
to enhance
ovarian cancer growth and metastatic ability.So to
test my hypothesis, I obtained normal BMI preadipocytes
from female donors or a female donor, and high
BMI preadipocytes from a different female donor.
And I did either a co-culture or a co-injection model
with GFP-labeled cancer cells. And
for the tumor model, I processed the tumors with FAC sorting
and also prepared tumor lysates. And for the tumor
model, I collected at an early time point during the tumor's
exponential growth phase, as well as a clinical endpoint.
And
normal BMI and high BMI preadipocyte injections generated tumors
similarly.
But at the early time point, the high BMI preadipocytes
had a significant increase in growth relative to injections of
cancer cells alone. And over the course of the whole study,
the high BMI preadipocytes had a decrease in the
probability of survival.
When I collected these tumors for FAC sorting, I found that there was
an equal abundance of GFP-positive cells within the tumors.
So I collected these cells for RNA, and I did a qPCR.
And
I tested for SOX2 gene expression, and I found that there was an
increase in the normal and high BMI
setting. And this was interesting to us because SOX2 has
been indicative of these tumor-initiating cell
populations. And then at the later time points,
there was a significant increase in the high BMI preadipocyte
group. So this data is suggesting that the preadipocytes
are enhancing tumor initiation through SOX2 potentially,
but the high BMI preadipocytes are enhancing
ECM remodeling through fibronectin.
In co-culture, I found that there was increased IGF secretion
between both normal and high BMI preadipocytes.
And then in the tumor lysates, I found a trending increase of
phosphorylated NF-kappa B activity.
But as far as the non-canonical NF-kappa B, RelB
processing, I found that it was high in the late tumors, but there were
no
clear differences among the groups.
So this data, along with my preliminary serum
deprivation experiments and IGF stimulation,
indicate that IGF may provide a survival advantage through
phosphorylated p65, and this may be
modulated by the OB setting.
I collected conditioned media from these preadipocytes, and I did
a cytokine array, and I found that there was an increase in
pro-inflammatory factors such as IL-6 or MCP-1, as well as
increase in growth factors like HGF and
FGF. But in the normal BMI setting, there
was increased IGFBP binding proteins, and this
is
indicating that since these binding proteins are inhibiting
free IGF-1, there may be more
bioavailable IGF in the OB setting.
So
to summarize this talk, I found that IGF signaling
is driving omental colonization by inducing NF-kappa B
transcription factor activity, that these obesity-induced
changes in preadipocytes are contributing to early tumor growth
and a decreased survival probability in the mice,
and that the high BMI environment may drive tumor initiation through
SOX2 expression, as well as enhancing tumor survival
and ECM remodeling through fibronectin.
And my current goal right now will be to define
the mechanistic role of IGF in an obesity-induced metastatic
potential model in vivo. So with that, I would like
to acknowledge my lab and
my committee members, as well as our funding resources.
And thank you to AACR for providing this opportunity to speak here.
Thank you for your attention.
Questions, please.
Very nice talk. I
have been thinking as you were speaking, and actually in some of the
other talks, there seems to be a
controversy emerging about the type of fat
that matters, and I guess I'm thinking about brown or
beige fat versus the white adipose tissue.
And I wonder if that question is something that
impacts the work you're doing. Does it matter-
Mm-hmm
... what type of adipocyte we're talking about in terms of fat
tissue?
Yeah. Both brown and white adipose tissue have different
thermogenic properties-
Right
... for the body. But
as far as the adiposity of the
individual, I think, yeah, my preadipocytes are from higher normal
BMI patients,
but I think there can be a better clear distinction of
this visceral adiposity versus a-
Mm
... general increase in BMI. And I think that
incorporating a better metric along with BMI, such
as waist-to-hip ratio or waist circumference,
for these ovarian cancer patients may be indicative of maybe their
metastatic prognosis. So, yeah.
And another question I had. So
adipocytes are also known to interact with immune cells and sort
of educate immune cells in environment.
And IGF-1
data is clear that adipocytes can release it, affect
cancer cells, and so on. Do you consider any role
in immune education?
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, I think with-From my preliminary data, I'm also
seeing that mature adipocytes also secrete IGF-1, yes.
But with the immune
crosstalk, I have not dove straight into that
just yet. But with these preliminary cytokine arrays, it's
indicating that, and also this classical NF-kappa B activation that
I'm seeing
with the high BMI, it could definitely lead me down
towards that way too. So that's something I will be unraveling
in my mouse model.
Yes.
Hi, that was a really interesting talk.
I was just curious if right now you have it kind of bended low onto normal and high
BMI.
Mm-hmm.
But have you gone through and maybe plot the BMI individually and see if
there's a dose response for increasing BMI?
No, I have not. Because the background data that I
was showing, the morbidly obese setting significantly enriched for
IGF, yeah.
But I have not
dove into a dose, like if you're underweight
versus overweight versus obese and morbid.
I have not gone into that just yet, yeah.
Mm-hmm.
Great question, though.
Thank you.
In addition to
IGF-1, any role
for metabolites released from adipocytes?
Mm.
What they can provide to cancer cells to make survival
better.
Mm-hmm.
When we knock down RelB
expression, we see changes in lipid metabolism
in cancer cells, which is very interesting.
But I have not gone into
the BMI story of that yet, whether an
enrichment of lipids and an abundance of adipocytes
there, whether if we inject cells with RelA knockdown or RelB
knockdown, whether that can change. But yeah, very interesting point.
Yes.
In the high BMI patients, frequently, patients
have insulin resistance.
Mm-hmm.
And the insulin-resistant patients, fat is releasing
fatty acids, and you get an inflammatory milieu.
And so I'm just
fascinated and interested that you were able to isolate
IGF-1 in the sort of vast interconnectedness
of metabolism and inflammation.
Mm-hmm. Yeah, I think as far as fatty acids
go, it's been published in ovarian cancer that FABP4
is an integral mediator of fatty acid intake
into the cancer cells, and that this is mediated by the adipocytes.
So what I'm really trying to unravel is the specific factors from
pre-adipocytes that are less studied as mature
adipocytes, and how they're able to regulate inflammation or
potentially regulate metabolism in ovarian cancer
metastasis.
But yeah, very interesting point, and yeah.
Just one other question. I
noticed adiponectin was low-
Mm-hmm.
in these patients. Have you thought about using
the drug that stimulates PPAR gamma
to see if you can compensate that?
We do have that in the lab. I've mainly been using it for
adipogenesis studies
for pre-adipocytes to adipocytes.
But
I think that would be interesting to
further interrogate the role of PPAR gamma signaling and maybe
with NF-kappa B too, if there's an interplay in metabolisms, yeah.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Okay, thank you so much.
So I believe our final speaker for today is Aram Liu
from Fred Hutch Cancer Center, and he will talk about
immunotherapy resistance to bone metastasis mediated
by myeloid-driven mechanisms.
I thank the organizers for this opportunity. My name is Aram Liu.
I'm a post-doctoral fellow under the mentorship of Dr.
Larry Fong at Fred Hutch Cancer Center.
Today, I'll be presenting how myeloid cell-mediated immunotherapy
resistance mechanisms evolve during prostate cancer progression,
particularly in bone metastasis.
I have nothing to disclose.
Prostate cancer is among the most common male malignancies.
Although immunotherapies, including immune checkpoint blockade, have
revolutionized cancer treatment, patients with advanced prostate
cancer remain largely unresponsive to these therapeutic
options. For example, patients treated with atezolizumab,
which is PD-L1 blockade, shown in blue, showed marginal
efficacy compared to those treated with control arms.
This therapeutic resistance is partly due
to the presence of immunosuppressive tumor microenvironment.
Particularly, tumor-associated myeloid cells are
encouraging and promising immunotherapeutic targets.
It's been well reported that immunosuppressive myeloid cells,
including macrophages on the left and another suppressing
myeloid population called myeloid-derived suppressor cells, become
significantly enriched during prostate cancer progression.
However, efforts to target these myeloid cells broadly, such as
with CSFR1 receptor blockade, showed minimal efficacy
in patients.
So our lab hypothesized that if we
identify distinct immunosuppressive myeloid
subpopulations that signals a resolution, we may be able to
enhance immunotherapy efficacy in
patients.To address this question,
we have previously investigated the primary tumor
biopsies across multiple stages and identified
a distinct macrophage population expressing elevated
levels of SPP1 transcript, which encodes the protein
osteopontin.
These macrophages become significantly enriched during disease
progression with enriched immunosuppressive molecular
programs.
Through preclinical studies, we demonstrated
that these macrophages drive immunotherapy resistance, shown
in blue versus red, via adenosine signaling
pathways. So these findings inform the clinical trial
showing that blockade of adenosine receptor
synergize with atezolizumab, shown in red, compared to
monotherapies. And these macrophage
population may serve as predictive biomarkers.
Although these longitudinal studies have provided
significant clinical insights,
these findings were primarily derived from primary
tumors.
And prostate cancer tend to spread to multiple organs,
including bone, liver, and lymph nodes.
And given majority of patients ultimately succumb to metastatic
disease, we hypothesize that if we characterize
myeloid departments across multiple metastatic organs,
we may be able to distinct these immunotherapeutic targets.
To address this question, we added more primary biopsies,
particularly from metastatic organs, to existing single
cell transcriptomes and conducted further transcriptional
analysis.
We found that a distinct organ has a unique
immune and non-immune environment, notably bone
metastasis, which is the most common organ of
prostate cancer spread, showed a unique tumor
microenvironment with neutrophils as a dominant component,
shown in green.
Importantly, we found that SPP1 high macrophages
that we reported showed a marginal scarcity
in bone metastasis compared to soft tissue sites,
highlighting the need for organ-specific investigations.
So we hypothesize that single cell characterization of myeloid
cells, particularly neutrophils in bone metastasis, may
reveal immunotherapeutic targets.
To address this question, we combined prostate cancer bone
biopsies with tumor-free bone samples and then performed further
single-cell analysis.
We identify multiple neutrophil subpopulations
corresponding to their developmental trajectories.
Notably, a mature neutrophil with elevated
expression of IL1B became
significantly enriched in tumor bone biopsies,
and we orthogonally confirmed their presence at protein levels
in bone biopsies.
Using a published gene signature of immune suppression, we found that
our target neutrophils show elevated immune-suppressive molecular
programs compared to other neutrophil subpopulations.
So we hypothesize that these IL1B mature
neutrophil may play a critical role in driving immunotherapy
resistance in prostate cancer bone metastasis.
To investigate in more detail, we utilize preclinical models.
We developed intraosseous prostate cancer model by
engrafting syngenic mouse prostate cancer directly into the
tibia.
We collected the cells from tumor-bearing bones and then conducted
single cell profiling along with characterization of
cell surface antigen.
Using systemic cross-transcriptional comparisons
between the species, we found analogous mature neutrophils
in our intraosseous models. And consistent with human
data, our target neutrophils show elevated immune-suppressive
molecular programs, suggesting that these neutrophils are well
recapitulated in our model.
Using cell surface markers revealed by our multi-omics
sequencing, including CD62L and CXCR2,
we successfully confirmed their presence at protein levels.
To test whether they are immunosuppressive, we isolated these
neutrophils and co-cultured them with activated
CD8 T cells.
The horizontal axis represents proliferation of T cells, and
we found that these neutrophils potently suppress T cell
proliferation and activation, at least in culture.
To test the relevance in vivo, we generated two cohorts of
mice, one with subcutaneous prostate cancer,
another with intraosseous prostate cancer.
It's been well reported that subcutaneously engrafted prostate cancer
respond to immune checkpoint blockade, shown in gray versus
red. So we reasoned that if our target
neutrophils drive immunotherapy resistance, if we
transfer these neutrophils from intraosseous prostate
cancer into subcutaneous prostate cancer, then
this introduction may confer therapeutic
resistance. Indeed, when we introduced our
target neutrophils, those subcutaneous tumors significantly
became
resistant to immune checkpoint blockade, suggesting that our target
neutrophils mediate resistance to checkpoint blockade in vivo.
To investigate the molecular mechanisms, we carried out pathway
analysis using differentially expressed genes and then crossed the
species to identify conserved activation of the
pathways.And we found that inflammation-related
pathways were highly upregulated in our target neutrophils.
And further computation analysis implicated IL-1
receptor pathway as a key mechanism.
To explore this possibility, we initiated co-culture of our
target neutrophils with
activated CD8 T cells in the presence or absence of CD1
receptor blockade. Indeed, immune suppression mediated
by our target neutrophils were significantly reduced following
IL-1 receptor inhibition.
To test the relevance in vivo, we developed intraosseous prostate
cancer and treated the cohort with immune checkpoint blockade
in the presence or absence of IL-1 receptor antagonist.
Consistent with human data, immune checkpoint blockade alone showed
minimal efficacy, shown in blue.
And IL-1 receptor inhibition also didn't show
significant impact. However, when we combined these
together, tumor growth significantly reduced, suggesting that
IL-1 receptor blockade can enhance immune checkpoint blockade efficacy
in intraosseous prostate cancer.
Lastly, to investigate clinical perspective, we
analyzed a published
symposium consortium data, including bone
biopsies.
We stratified the patients using our mature
neutrophil signature scores, and we found the elevated
target neutrophil signature scores are highly associated with
reduced survival, shown in gray versus red.
Moreover, our target neutrophil signature scores
also significantly correlate with increased immune suppression,
as well as inflammation-mediated immune suppression, suggesting that
our preclinical findings well align with those patient
perspective.
In summary, our lab has identified a distinct
mature neutrophil expressing elevated IL-1 beta
transcript in prostate cancer bone metastases.
These neutrophils are functionally immunosuppressive, and the blockade of
inflammatory signals, particularly IL-1 receptor,
enhance the efficacy of these therapeutic options.
An elevated IL-1 beta high mature neutrophil signature scores
correlate with inferior survival.
With that, I'd like to thank Dr. Larry Fong for his unwavering support
and mentorship, and I thank our lab members and
longstanding collaborators. And last but not least, I thank
our funding sources, particularly Prostate Cancer Foundation,
for supporting this presentation.
Thank you for listening and happy to take questions.
Yeah.
I have a question.
Is it black and white,
SPP1 macrophages under the skin or
orthotopically work, and then IL-1 beta neutrophils
work in the bone and there is no role for SPP
macrophages there?
Yes. So the question, if I understand correctly, whether
SPP1 high Macs are more restricted to primary tumors,
whereas
our target neutrophils are limited to the bone metastases.
Am I understanding correctly? Yes.
So
other metastatic sites need to be further explored when I
compare primary tumors versus bone metastases.
Although I found multiple neutrophil
subpopulations, I couldn't find these
IL-1 beta high mature neutrophils in primary tumors,
suggesting that those neutrophils, at least in the context of
prostate cancer, may be more limited to bone
metastases compared to other sites.
Thank you. Please.
Hi,
I'm Amy Leslie. I'm from Stanford.
And because we're talking prostate cancer, we got to talk about AR.
And so thinking back to Amy Moran's and Felix Swings'
paper on how enzalutamide and targeting AR
changes the immune microenvironment and activates
MHC-1,
how do you think that recapitulates
in terms of AR positive and AR negative and how that affects the immunosuppressive
microenvironment, especially in terms of neutrophils?
Are they affected by the AR signaling access or not?
That's a great question, and it needs to be determined, at least
for SPP1 macrophages. When I looked
into AR expression in those macrophage
populations and across the myeloid populations, their
transcriptional expressions were quite marginal, suggesting that they
may not be highly impacted by AR. But in terms
of IL-1 beta mature neutrophils, I haven't done that
analysis or experiment yet. So, thank you for the
great question.
Thanks.
Mm-hmm.
So conditioning with... Over to this mic.
Tony Letai, NCI.
Conditioning with cytotoxic chemotherapy
is generally found to be necessary to have an effective CAR T cell
treatment.
It's often considered that this cytotoxic therapy is necessary for
lymphocyte reduction. Do you think instead it could be
an important effect is myeloid cell reduction?
So if I
received the question correctly, so whether these-
I'm just saying we always give cytotoxic chemotherapy-
Mm-hmm.
... to condition people before they get CAR T cells.
Yes.
And if we don't do that, they don't work well.
Mm-hmm.
Typically, it's thought that we
need to give that chemo to do lymphoreduction,
lymphodepletion.
Mm-hmm.
Is it possible, based on your findings-
Mm-hmm
... that myeloid depletion is every bit as important as lymphodepletion, and that
we're actually doing myeloid depletion with some of these chemotherapy regimens?
Well,
as a myeloid cell immunologist, not all myeloid
populations are bad.
During the disease progression, myeloid cells are reprogrammed
into suppressive phenotypes. So I am
relatively against the concept of broad ablation.
I would rather more focus on how to
reprogram bad myeloid populations into
initially good, as part of innate immunity,
myeloid populations. But I don't have experimental
evidence, so I cannot say this confidently.
But I think ablating myeloid cells could
be playing a role there. Thank you for the question.
Maybe I was just going to comment on this last question.
I think one of the things
we've seen, like even with checkpoint inhibition, actually, most of
the efficacy that we see is in combination with chemotherapy.
And I think for many folks studying immunotherapies, that's
always been a bit of a conundrum. People think about potentially
debulking the tumors, but there may be a myeloid reset that
is associated with that. It may be a blunt tool to do that, but
it's a provocative idea.
Yes. Agreed.
So prostate cancer isn't the only cancer that
metastasizes to the bone. Breast cancer patients
often have this happen. Do you think that
what you're observing is restricted to prostate cancer,
or would we expect some of these changes in, say, breast
cancer?
Yes. So, I would say the enrichment of our target
neutrophils may not be restricted to prostate
cancer. However,
relative recent articles suggested
that other subsets of neutrophils, inflammatory
neutrophils expressing chitinase, particularly in the
context of triple negative breast cancer.
Phils
may not be restricted, but it's not
frequent or observed in at least bone trophic
breast cancer.
Okay. Thank you.
So I'm charged with providing a summary, and I will be blessedly
brief. I think we've heard some incredibly
good talks, very exciting and
future-directed, I think.
And what impresses me the most is, even though this session
was entitled "Microenvironmental
Determinants," which is true,
I'm struck by the systemic nature
of the talks that we heard today in terms of how
things like obesity, the nerve, brain
stress, the microbiome,
sleep deprivation, all of these
clearly systemic events, inflammation,
change from primary tumors to metastatic tumors,
are affecting the tumor microenvironment, and I
think that this has really opened up far
more ideas than we originally
thought of when we think about cancer hallmarks.
There is going to be some great additions
from the system, and I'm particularly intrigued myself
with psychological stress and the role of nerves.
But I'm impressed today with the incredible
presentations that we saw on a variety of other factors as
well. So I hope you all take home some new
ideas and think about the systemic nature
and control of the tumor microenvironment.
And thanks to all the speakers. I'm really impressed
with the quality of the presentations.
We both are very
happy with what we learned, and I hope you are too.
So enjoy the rest of the evening, and thanks to all our speakers.